el presidente de la república Guillermo
lasso ha autorizado el porte de armas
para la defensa personal de civiles como
una medida de emergencia urgente ante el
borde de la criminalidad
66,4% de incremento de las muertes
violentas entre el primero de enero y el
20 de marzo de 2023 según cifras del
Ministerio de interior y Justicia La
decisión presidencial también es vista
como una oportunidad en establecimientos
dedicados a la venta de equipos para la
defensa personal soy por hoy con esta
ley que se puede se pueda dar Entonces
será ya una mayor seguridad para uno
como usuario poder portar o poder
protegernos de alguna manera en Ecuador
el 92% de los crímenes se produjeron en
los espacios públicos y es aquí donde la
medida despierta el debate entre los
Ecuatorianos en el año 2022 se
registraron 4,603 homicidios científicos
10,4 casos diarios de una tasa de 25
muertes violentas por cada 100.000
habitantes pero la medida aplicada por
el primer mandatario es descabellado
para algunos y acertada para otros
para mí va a haber más violencia o sea
es una seguridad de pronto pero igual
Claro entre comillas Pero va a traer
violencia más violencia personalmente
estoy hablando de que sería necesario
tanto a los hombres como mujeres porque
razón porque ahora a nivel nacional
la delincuencia está reinando nos aquí
en el país para el crimen académico en
seguridad en el pontón es una medida que
puede incrementar la violencia asegura
que solo Busca enfrentar la principal
debilidad del ejecutivo nacional que es
la inseguridad y la lucha entre las
bandas criminales que se pelean por
territorio para el narcotráfico una
mayor urgente para enfrentar la
violencia actualmente No creo o el
crimen
si es una digamos una política que de
alguna otra forma reviste un cierto Abre
de popularidad Buscar refrescar sus
popularidad 11 estados de sección se han
aplicado en dos años de gestión
presidencial para intentar enfrentar la
criminalidad que desborda en este país
que coincide con el inicio formal del
juicio político en contra del presidente
de la república y el asesinato del
principal implicado en la investigación
en su contra